bis in die nacht hinein bis in den
späten abend zumindest noch hinterzimmer
treffen hier überall im politischen
berlin vor allen dingen in unionsreihen
jahren und jetzt nach diesen ganzen
hinterzimmer treffen und vor dieser so
spannenden fraktionssitzungen am
nachmittag wie stark ist dann auch der
kanzlerkandidat der union armin laschet
also wir laufen auf den ersten countdown
zu auf die erste wirklich gravierende
entscheidung nach der bundestagswahl am
sonntag und die wird stattfinden heute
abend in der unionsfraktion gibt einen
beinharten machtkampf zwischen armin
laschet dem wahlverlierer und dem
fraktionschef folgendes ist geplant
armin laschet will dass der
fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus nur
kommissarisch dieses amt weiterführen
weil er vielleicht das selbst irgendwann
ausführen möchte oder eine regierung
bilden möchte und jemand von seinem
gutdünken auf diesem posten sieht und
ralph brinkhaus sieht das komplett
anders der will sich wählen lassen und
zwar richtig und zwar für ein jahr so
und jetzt gibt es diesen machtkampf
laschet sagt nein brinkhaus sagt ja und
es wird telefoniert die ganze nacht auch
heute morgen ralph brinkhaus ist sehr
aktiv ruft sehr sehr viele abgeordnete
an in der hoffnung dass sie für ihn
stimmen ihn zum fraktionsvorsitzenden
machen und wenn das so kommen sollte
dann ist es zum einen eine dramatische
niederlage für armin laschet weil es das
gegenteil ist was er möchte und zum
zweiten wird erwartet dass nicht nur
ralph brinkhaus dann antritt sondern
möglicherweise auch noch andere auf den
plan treten jens spahn beispielsweise
norbert röttgen möglicherweise
vielleicht carsten linnemann friedrich
merz das heißt dann hätte man plötzlich
eine eruption dort in der fraktion viele
viele die sich wählen lassen möchten und
das wäre das letzte was armin laschet
jetzt noch gebrauchen kann warum
klammert er sich weiterhin so an die
macht warum klammert er sich immer noch
an diese jamaica aussicht die die zahlen
belegen ist auch die wählerinnen und
wähler inzwischen auch gar nicht mehr
wollen und auch das wahlergebnis zeigt
ja dass das nicht die favorisierte
option ist analysiert uns das einmal
reif waren klammert er sich so dran zum
einen ist es armin laschet lebensmotto
ich mache weiter ich ziehe durch ich
gebe nicht vorher auf und wenn mich das
leben irgendwo raus kegelt gut dann habe
ich verloren aber bis dahin mache ich
weiter und mit dieser methode ist ja
sehr weit gekommen das andere ist es
gehört einfach zu den grundtugenden in
der politik dazu nicht vorfristig
hinzuschmeißen bevor nicht eine schlacht
verloren ist sonst schafft man das nie
durch die gremien und durch die ganzen
machtkämpfe durch das andere ist in der
union gibt es eine große unsicherheit
wenn dieses zentrum des
parteivorsitzenden und spitzenkandidaten
wenn das weg ist dann gibt es ein freies
spiel der kräfte und das will man genau
vermeiden war im freien spiel kann man
nicht sagen wer am ende gewinnt und die
union ist sehr strukturiert und sehr
macht orientiert und da möchte man
einfach dass irgend jemand da ist der
zumindest auch wenn eher schwach ist
diesen prozess noch moderiert und leitet
nun kann man deals machen dann kann man
sagen okay ich kriege diesen posten
nicht aber ich habe einen anderen
zugesprochen bekommen das geht alles
nicht wenn man kampfkandidaturen hat und
gegeneinander steht dann muss man
kämpfen und am ende fallen dann leute
runter die sich große karrieren hoffnung
gemacht haben jetzt will dir überall
auch in diesen hinterzimmer runden die
handys klingeln sms auf das handy mit
neuen informationen usw jan sag uns
einmal habt ihr jemanden gefunden der
100% ganz stramm hinter armin laschet
steht es gibt einige beispielsweise
friedrich merz die zumindest auch in
internen runden immer noch dafür werben
dass armin laschet kanzler einer jamaika
koalition wird die gibt es aber das
liegt natürlich auch daran es ist die
letzte chance für friedrich merz
beispielsweise noch minister zu werden
also gibt es da so was wie ein
treuegelöbnis die frage ist wie lange
hält das aber es gab auch gestern runden
mit friedrich merz und da hat er nochmal
deutlich dafür geworben ein jamaika
bündnis einzugehen da man hat trotzdem
den eindruck und reift schularzt gerade
eben auch schon ein bisschen
angesprochen die union kommt nach 36
stunden delirium wischte sich offen oder
viele in der union zwischen sich jetzt
zu langsam den sand den schlafsand aus
den augen und stellen fest hoppla wir
haben die war ja wirklich gar nicht
geworden wir haben die ja in der tat
verloren also was jedem zuschauer ja
alles ist hatte dort zwar der stamm ist
eigentlich klar schröder moment von 2005
schröder hatte eine irre aufholjagd
hingelegt hatte verloren absolut aber
dachte er wäre trotzdem der wahlsieger
und so ähnlich ist es bei amira was
merken immer mehr in der union ii wir
haben ja gar nicht gewonnen stimmt ja
immer ein lügen gar nicht und die
menschen merken auch dass der winzig
gedreht hat und wir haben heute morgen
thema kuban beispielsweise den chef der
jungen union der immer
eine sehr starke stimme ist und oft die
union dann auch in die richtung führt in
dies dann geht der hat gesagt wir müssen
einmal konstatieren wir haben die wahl
verloren punkt und der ball ich erstmal
bei der spd also deutliche worte die
darauf hindeuten wir sehen die letzten
48 stunden möglicherweise von armin
laschet das schlechte es historisch
schlechte wahlergebnis der union es hat
armin laschet damit zu tun wer schaut
mal rein wie er selbst als analysiert
und natürlich weiß ich auch dass ich
meine persönlichen anteil an diesem
wahlergebnis habe wir haben besprochen
dass wir das alles intensiv aufarbeiten
das werden wir tun in einem
strukturierten prozess mit den
landesverbänden mit den kreisverbänden
und mit anderen an der basis der
generalsekretär wird dazu gleich noch
etwas sagen
und das werden wir tun
ganz gleich ob wir am ende dieses
prozesses in regierungsverantwortung
sind oder in der opposition auch in
regierungsverantwortung
muss seine erneuerung der union
stattfinden auf allen ebenen und das ist
das was wir dann gemeinsam besprechen
werde
die erneuerung auf allen ebenen davon
spricht armin laschet hier wieder doch
dafür dafür ist der weg sehr steinig und
sehr lang so sie zu diesem zeitpunkt auf
jeden fall aus weil uns weiterhin ralf
schuler und auch jan schäfer was könnte
armin laschet tun was könnte aus der
tasche zaubern damit dieser weg für ihn
irgendwie leichter wird zu mehren an der
waage sind die grünen sind die fdp man
muss ganz klar sagen derzeit sieht es
nicht danach aus dass die sich die
finger lecken nach amin asche nein das
ist natürlich eine verfahrene situation
über kreuz für die fdp ist es eine ganz
schwere vorstellung ein ampel bündnis
einzugehen und zwischen zwei linken
parteien zu sitzen und die chance haben
da aufgerieben zu werden für die grünen
wiederum die sich in einem
jamaika-bündnis begeben müssen ist es
genau umgekehrt die müssen sich zwischen
zwei bürgerliche und sehr dominante
parteien setzen und müssten dann sagen
warum sie ihre kampagne der für die
erneuerung gefahren haben aber mit dem
wahlverlierer mit dem schwer
abgestraften beifall ihrer in einem boot
sitzen das ist schwer argumentativ
durchzukriegen also für beide seiten ist
es relativ schwierig man muss allerdings
wissen dass die union sehr stark
regional aufgestellt ist anders als die
spd wurde parteigremien im willy brandt
haus in berlin im prinzip die fäden in
der hand haben bei der union entscheiden
sehr stark die landesverbände und die
landesvorstände in allen bundesländern
haben gestern abend getagt und da war
die parole noch jetzt geschlossenheit
jetzt nichts überstürzen
vorsicht wir dürfen jetzt nicht so sehr
den armin laschet kritisch kritisieren
in hessen beispielsweise wollen wir auch
rein gehört haben gab es gestern abend
heftige debatten haben sich mehrere zu
wort gemeldet haben gesagt es geht so
nicht weiter trotzdem wurde das alles
noch mal still gehalten auch bei armin
laschet selbst geschlossenheit wir
werden in ruhe auswerten doch früh am
nächsten morgen wenn die ganzen
kommentare vorliegen sehen jetzt mehr
und mehr abgeordnete dass eigentlich
niemand so richtig verstehen kann dass
armin laschet der linie sein sollte er
ein die verhandlung für jamaika führt
und ich glaube da kommt eine neue
dynamik eine neue dynamik sagst du das
war ja auch dass gerade schon jan was du
angedeutet dass vor allen dingen für den
nachmittag das können die doch vergessen
da in der union sowie armin laschet das
gerade sagt dass du ganz strukturiert
und in ruhe jetzt mal aufzuarbeiten man
sich zurückzulehnen papiere zu lesen was
ist da schiefgelaufen ist doch total
offensichtlich der kandidat hat nicht
funktioniert jetzt wartet man so lange
bis er dann endlich das selber
verstanden hat und die zeichen der zeit
erkennt zurücktritt wie lange wird so
etwas dauern und brechen da
möglicherweise heute nachmittag schon
alle dämme und vorbei ist es mit diesem
strukturierten prozess die erneuerung
kommt schneller als man denkt also klar
ist es wird ganz ganz viel gerade
telefoniert in der unionsfraktion und es
ist fast so ein bisschen wie so ein zug
armin laschet im ein bahnhof olaf scholz
zum anderen bahnhöfen und man sieht
richtig wie der zug im langsamen aber
fällt auch in schnellerem tempo den zug
von armin laschet den bahnen von armin
laschet er verlässt und auf olaf scholz
zurück also der zug der macht versucht
noch irgendwie eine bremse einzuziehen
oder ihn zu halten aber olaf scholz weiß
und das zeigt auch zeigen diese
gelassenen auftritte eigentlich er weist
dieser zug der macht der rollt er auf
ihn zu und es ist halt in der unions
fraktion derzeit so es gibt eine ganz
unterschiedliche gemengelagen es gibt
einige die wollen ralph brinkhaus weise
dieses signal setzen wollen armin
laschet du hast verloren wir wollen
jetzt quasi einen machtkampf gegen dich
auch gewinne es gibt andere die aber
sagen wir wollen dass armin laschet
abtritt aber wir wollen nicht reif
brinkhaus die also jetzt
herumtelefoniert andere haben an die
marie heraus kommen aber es gibt ja das
sagt aber auch wieder in der union gibt
es immer noch und reif hat auch gerade
gesagt eine strukturierte partei es gibt
auch abgeordnete sagen ohne stehen jetzt
die die auftreten bei uns liche partei
vielleicht auch eine sehr ängstlicher
partei absolut recht kommen die denn
heute aus der deckung also könnte es
überraschend passieren dass hier
entspannen heute nachmittag plötzlich
sagt so leute das hier überhaupt was ich
nicht mag sagen das gehört überraschend
passieren und das ist ja genau das was
armin laschet verhindern will aber genau
das kann passieren dass jens spahn aus
der deckung kommt wenn er feststellt
ralph brinkhaus will wirklich antreten
und sich damit gegen laschet stellen so
das könnte bedeuten dass auch jens spahn
sagt ich gehe raus das lasse ich mir
nicht bieten er reist brinkhaus du bist
nicht mein mann nicht nennen möchte
jedem ich möchte selbst machen es kann
auch sein dass norbert röttgen dann
rauskommt der sich ja auch bereit hält
und warum läuft es kann auch sein dass
gleich nach friedrich merz oder carsten
linnemann wer weiß das schon also das
könnte zu einem richtigen showdown heute
kommen ab 18 uhr in der unionsfraktion
[Musik]